hey this is preshtalwalka reminding you
to mind your decisions
here's a problem i received by email
about two years ago
if a b c and d are positive integers
with a sum of 63 what is the maximum
value of a b plus bc plus cd
i did some research and the problem
traces back to the australian
intermediate olympiad in 2013.
this is a test for talented students who
are in the years of seven through ten
which i believe is the ages of 11
through 15.
the test consists of 4 hours to solve 10
problems and no calculators are allowed
and remember students haven't taken
calculus yet so limit yourself to
solving this problem using geometry and
algebra
i'll admit it's a very hard problem i
wasn't able to solve it
if you'd like to give it a try pause the
video right now and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
[Music]
so how are we even supposed to maximize
the quantity a b plus bc plus cd
it seems like such an abstract thing why
would anyone want to maximize this to
get a better sense of what this sum is
let's use an area model we'll construct
rectangles whose areas are each of these
terms
let's first construct a rectangle whose
area is a b
we have one length of a and a width of b
this rectangle will have an area of a b
to get bc we add a length of c and this
rectangle will have an area bc
to get cd we add a width of d and this
rectangle will be an area of cd
now just for fun let's complete this
rectangle
this final rectangle here will have an
area of a d
what the area model shows us is that a b
plus b c plus c d is the sum of the blue
areas and that will be the area of the
entire rectangle which has sides a plus
c and b plus d
minus the small rectangle a
we thus get the following algebraic
identity
how is that going to help us
well to maximize the blue areas we can
equivalently maximize the area of this
rectangle minus a d we can then use some
geometric insight
for a fixed length and width the sum of
the blue aries is maximum if a is as
small as possible
all of the variables have to be positive
integers so the smallest positive
integer will be a is equal to 1.
let's visualize why this is true
now similarly
for a fixed length and width the sum of
the blue areas is maximum if d is as
small as possible
so we need d to be the smallest positive
integer which is one
here's a visualization of that
we therefore have translated the problem
into something a little more manageable
we have a maximization problem with two
variables c and b
we can further simplify this
recall that the sum of all the variables
is 63 we deduce that a and d need to be
equal to one
and this means that b plus c have to be
equal to 61 or b is equal to 61 minus c
we can substitute that back into our
original expression and we end up with
an optimization problem in just one
variable c
we can then expand this binomial and
simplify
to get that we need to optimize a
quadratic equation
how can we solve for the maximum value
of this expression
we'll use some more geometry
in a parabola with an equation alpha x
squared plus beta x plus gamma is equal
to zero
we know that its maximum and minimum
will be at its vertex and its vertex
happens when x is equal to negative beta
over two alpha and alpha cannot be equal
to zero
if we use this formula for the
expression we're trying to maximize we
end up that c needs to be equal to
negative 61 over negative two and this
simplifies to be 30.5
but we're not done yet
remember that c has to be a positive
integer so we'll try the closest integer
values of c is equal to 30 and c is
equal to 31. we also want the maximum
value so let's calculate this
remarkably in either case we get the
maximum value is equal to 991
and that's our answer
so what seemed like an impossible
problem turns out to be something we can
understand through geometry
incredible
thanks for watching and making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
[Music]
you